[موسيقى]
طب تم طابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار
الساعه نبداها بابرز العناوين
بعد نتائج
استقالته من رئاسه مجلس اداره تويتر
ريهانهم على موقف برلين من الازمه
في الاردن مداهمه تطيح بخليه ارهابيه في
معان وتصفي قاتل الدلابيح الامن العام
يبدا بملاحقه المحرضين
معركه باخمود حسن لموسكو ومفتاحها لدونس
اوكرانيه تدافع بقوه عن حسنها الشرقيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اوفى ايلون ماسك بوعده واعلن انه
سي يتنحى عن رئاسه تويتر وذلك بعد استفتاء
حول بقائه في هذا المنصب بل الاستطلاع
الذي دعا اليه مصر لم يصب في صالحه حيث
ايد مستخدم تويتر تنحيه من منصبه وذلك في
استطلاع شارك فيه اكثر من 17 مليون شخص
ونصف مليون شخص واصوت حواليك 58% لصالح
تنحيه ماسك طبعا كان حماسك من رئاسه تويتر
بينما صوت 42% من اجل بقائه في منصبه
باستقاله ماسك فان رئاسه تويتر ستكون
قدامه ثلاثه 53 يوم فقط لهذا الرجل وكان
ماسك قد اعترف بارتكابه خطا في اطلاق قيود
جديده على التعبير مناعه الاشاره لمواقع
اخرى للتواصل الاجتماعي على تويتر
منذ ان حتى الطائر الازرق في قفص
الملياردير ماسك لم تنفك التغييرات تطارد
تويتر اخرها حظر الحسابات المستخدمه
للترويج لمنصه تواصل اجتماعيا اخرى مثل
الفيسبوك والانستغرام
المنافس لتويتر خطوه لاقت معارضه واسعه
خاصه من المؤسس المشارك لتويتر جاك دورسي
الذي وصفها بالخطوه التي لا معنى لها
القرار جاء بعد ايام قليله من تعليق
حسابات صحفيين على تويتر بحجه عدم
امتثالهم لسياسته الجديده دوكسينج
والمتعلقه بنشر المعلومات
ومع الضغوط التي تعرض لها وجد ماسك نفسه
امام خيار الطرح الاستطلاع راي على حسابه
لاعاده تفعيل الحسابات او ابقائها مغلقه
عمليه تعليق الحسابات اثاره غضب الحكومات
والافراد حول العالم معتبرين انها تقويم
لحريه الصحافه وتناقض ما دعى اليه ماسك
نفسه عند استحوده على تويتر
في ظل كل الاحداث المكثفه التي مر بها
تويتر خلال اقل من شهرين من تولي ماسك
المنصب والقيود التي وضعها على المستخدمين
بينما يحاول جعلهم ان يدفعوا مقابل
الخدمات يتجه العديد من المستخدمين الى
منصه اخرى بحسب اكسس
ضغوط كبيره خلال فتره قصيره ربما كانت
السبب وراء استطلاع الراي الذي نشره ماسك
على تويتر
متسائلا اذا ما كان يجب ان يتخلى عن منصبه
في تويتر ما قد يجعله خارج اسوار المنصه
الاكثر شعبيه الى عمر العربيه
الى اخبار الساعه
يعني هذا الخبر
كان هناك فيديو نشر على انه بالفعل يتناول
لكن هذا الفيديو يبدو انه اختفى اين ذهب
ما القصه هناك لبس
نعم يعني بعد اعلان نتيجه الاستفتاء الذي
وصف باستفتاء التنحي لايون ماسك كان هناك
تحليلات وتعليقات بانو سيتم التنحي في
غضون الساعات المقبله احد المصادر تحدث
ونشر فيديو كما ذكرت عدل عن تنحي الين
ماسك رسميا حاولنا اتصال الاتصال بمصادرنا
في تويتر ولكن لا احد يجيب هناك تعتيم تام
على هذا الخبر حتى هناك المغردون يسالون
قالوا ماسك شخصيه على حسابه على تويتر
ولكن لا تعليق وكانه ماسك نفسه اختفى عن
عن الوجود على هذه المنصه تحديدا همم ولكن
المحللون اجمع ايضا على انه الان ننتظر
فقط الاعلان عن الرئيس التنفيذي الجديد
همم تويتر في هذه المرحله همم الحساسه جدا
من التويتر بعد حوالي شهرين فقط على
استحواذ لهن ماسك على هذه المنصه الشهيره
وكانت فتره كما وصفوها بالساخنه ومثيره
للجدل دائما ادت الى تراجع همم اهميه هذه
المنصه وكانت ك- وصفت بالزلزال لهذه
المنصه التي
كان الكثير من الصحفيين
والامريكيين وفي العالم همم يهتمون بها
همم تحديدا هذه اول مره يختفي قالوا ماسك
عن الوجود في العالم الافتراض خاصه بهذا
الموضوع الذي يتناوله هو شخصيا في هذه
المرحله الكل في انتظار الاعلان عن التنحي
والاعلان المنتظر اكثر هو الاعلان عن
الرئيس التنفيذي المقبل الذي سيبقى همم
تويتر على قيد الحياه ليس فقط
ان يلقي تويتر على مرشحه لهذا الرئيس
التنفيذي هل من ردود افعال على الاقل من
انه ماذا سيكون يعني مستقبل تويتر
ابدا كل التفاصيل التي ننتظرها الان هي
الاعلان عن الرئيس التنفيذي الذي من خلاله
سنفهم السياسه التي ستتبع في الفتره
المقبله ل همم تويتر خاصه بظل الانتقادات
الواسعه التي تلقاها ايلون ماسك في الفتره
الاخيره في الايام الاخيره
والازمه الاخيره مع الصحفيين الامريكيين
التي انتهت بوصفه بانه قاتل حريه الصحافه
وهذا امر غير مقبول تماما في الولايات
المتحده كان هناك انتقادات وجهات همم
للناس من ان كان من الامم المتحده او حتى
من الاتحاد الاوروبي الذين رفضوا اجراءاته
بالتعليق حسابات صحفيه امريكيه ليس لشيء
فقط لانه اثاره غضبه همم بقضايا شخصيه
واعتبروا انه هذا الامر لا يجب ان يتم مزج
الامور الشخصيه مع الامور العمليه وخاصه
على منصه تويتر
[موسيقى]
ويفعل فيها ما يشاء كما يقول البعض شكرا
جزيلا ريتا سليمان مراسله العربيه من
واشنطن
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا ايضا
الكاتب الصحفيه اهلا بك سيد رؤوف يعني هل
يريد كسب هذه الذوب على الاعلاميه وتصف في
مصلحه المنصه التي يدير لها حتى الان
ابني ابني
الشبكه الالكترونيه
فقط
على مدى 18 ساعه وكثير
التنفيذي
لكنه سيكون يعمل
وهذا سيشمل بكل الاحوال
كما قلت هي من السته يفعل بها ما يريد هو
يملكها فهي ملكيه خاصه علينا ان ننتظر
ماذا سيفعل وشك بانه همم
مسؤوليه همم
اداره هذه الشركه في حين ان لديه شركه
فضائيه وشركه سيارات وكثير من الشركات
الاخرى التي يسعى اليها فلا يريد ان يكون
في هذا العمل
العلاقات الاجتماعيه
وعندما يصبح واضح
ان تويتر لن تكون هي اييي سيطره كامله
للبراليين فهو اراد ان يضع يده ويسيطر
عليها بهذا الشكل طيب هل هو فعل ما يريد
خلال فتره الشهرين الذي ترى اسى فيها
تويتر وبالتالي طرد من طرد ومن كان يضلله
وفق رايه والان قد يدير هذه المنصه
الرقميه بوجه اخر وان كان رئيسا تنفيديا
فهو يعني عبر ستار
عايزين عايزين
صاحب الملكيه الكامله اللي او 50 بالمئه
زائد واحد من الاسهم للشركه بغض النظر عن
من سيكون المدير التنفيذي فسيكون تابع له
وسيعكس قيام مصر
والاهم الاول هو
تحقيق الربح
وهي همم شركه تواصل دون صنع مال او تحقيق
الربح هذا غير مقبول وهو يريد الربح كي
تبقى هذه الشركه بغض النظر عن العاملين
كلهم معروفين هم همم
يوضع على هذه الشبكه على هذه
نحن لسنا بحاجه لمثل هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين
تم التخلص منهم فقط كانوا افراد الشرطه
عقائديين همم يتخلصون من امور لا يحبونها
عبر تغريدات لا تعجبهم همم ربما كانوا
يصمتون اصواتا لا تعجبهم
شكرا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لدينا ايضا في اخر ساعه في اخبار الساعه
مفاجاه غير ساره لترامب لجنه التحقيق في
هجوم الكابتون تخلص الى ان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق غير مؤهل لتوليد منصب
الرسمي
حياكم الله في لقاء خاصه به قناه العربيه
قال رئيس مجلس القياده اليمنيه رشاد
العليمي بان الاداره الامريكيه ترد على
الادله التي يتم تقديمها والتي تثبت تورط
ايران في اليمن
ان نقنع المجتمع الدولي وفي المقدمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان هناك دعم ايراني غير محدود لهذه
الجماعه
وكان ونسلم ملفات بوثائق وادله متعدده
امريكا الى صنعاء كنا نسلم
ها للمتمردين فيصل
ولكن دائما يقولون ان الادله غير كافيه
قال نحن مقتنعين في البنتاجون وفي الشيعيه
ان هذه جماعه تتبع ايران ومدعومه من ايران
ولكن من يقنع البيت الابيض
كان زياره لالمانيا
لانه ندرك ان الموقف الالماني موقف مهم
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
والحوثيين كانوا يراهنوا كثيرا على على
على المواقف الالمانيه
وكان لهم تواجد عناصرهم همم
الناعمه اللي بنسميها اللي تتواجد في
اوروبا وفي امريكا وفي هذه المناطق
وحصل تغير في الموقع الاوروبي
معنا من عدن وكيل وزاره الاعلام اليمنيه
اسامه شرميه اهلا بك سيد اسامه يعني يتحدث
بدايه عن هذه المواقع التي شرحها الرئيس
العليم من الولايات المتحده والمانيا هذه
المواقف الدوليه تجاه الملف اليمني ماذا
تفسرها كيف يقراها الرجل الرئيس العلمي
طيب
اذا سنكون
معكم طيب سنبقى اذا سنعود الى اسامه شرميه
على جهوزه اذا نعود الى هذه اللقاء فيما
يتعلق بالهدنه اكد رشاد العليمي ان
الحوثيين ان لم يلتزموا بالهن منذ اكتوبر
الماضي تجديدها رغم كل الجهود المبذوله
واصفا اياها بالهدهشه
الواقع انه موضوع
الهدنه ااا نحن كما تعرف عندما تشكل مجلس
القياده الرئاسي كانت الهدنه قائمه وقمنا
بتجديد هذه المدينه من طرف الحكومه
الشرعيه
ولكن منذ اثنين اكتوبر الماضي همم
الميليشيات الحوثيين الارهابيه رفض
التمديد
رغم كل الجهود اللي بدلت سواء من الاشقاء
همم في قياده التحالف والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالدرجه الرئيسيه
والمبعوث الاممي والمبعوث الامريكي
والجهود ايضا العمانيه همم بدلت في هذا
الاتجاه ولكن للاسف همم رفضه الحوثيات
وحتى هذه اللحظه تجديد وطبعا كانت الهجره
[موسيقى]
في الاردن تتطور الاحداث بشكل متلاحق
لتتضح معها الصوره اكثر فاكثر حول
المتوردين في حادثه قتل ضابط الامن العميد
عبد الرزاق الدلابيب فقد وضع التاب مديريه
الامن العام هدف رئيسا بعد احداث الشعب
الاخيره وهو ضبط المشبه بهم في قتل
الدلابيح وهو مقتضى تنفيذ عمليه مداهمه
بعد ما قاده التحقيقات الى حصر المشتبهم
وهم بمجموعه بمجموعه من الاشقاء من حمله
الفكر التكفيري وفقه مديريات الامن العام
في تفاصيل عمليه المداهمه التي نشرتها
مديريه الامن العام في الاردن فان العمليه
الامنيه نفذتها قوه امنيه خاصه وتمت في
منطقه الحسن الحسينيه في محافظه معان جنوب
العاصمه عمان حيث تمت محاصره مكان وجود
المشبه بهم واسفره المداهمه عن ثلاثه قتله
من قوه الامن وعدد من الجرحى وايضا مقتل
احد المتورطين بعد اطلاقه النار كما
افضلتها المداهمه الى القاء القبض على
تسعه اشخاص اخرين مشتبه بتورثتهم في
القضيه منهم اربعه اشقاء وثلاثه اخرين من
اقاربهم ومعهم شخصان فضلا عن ذلك تم ضبط
مجموعه من الاسلحه الناريه الاوتوماتيكيه
وكميه كبيره من الدخيره بحوزه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
وفي مزيد من التفاصيل والادله التي تكشفت
بعد عمليه المداهمه تبين ان الارهاب
المقتول في العمليه لم يكن سوا قاتل
العميد
عن مدير الامن العام في الاردن الذي اكتشف
ايضا ان السلاح الارهابي المقتول هو نفسه
السلاح
واكد الامن العام ان الخليه الارهابيه
خططت لقتل العميد الاردني
من جانبه شقيق العميد عبد الرزاق الدلابيح
قال العربيه ان عائله العميد تثق في
الاجهزه الامنيه الاردنيه وتقف مع الدوله
مشيرا الى ان الاجهزه الامنيه اوفت بوحدها
واقتصت من قاتلهم
وعلنا من البدايه بان مع الاردن مع الوطن
مع الاجهزه الامنيه واصالنا بيان امبارح
اعطينا الاجهزه الامنيه المده الكافيه من
اجل انه اظهار الحق واظهار القتله القتل
بين ومعلومات اوليه الحمد لله رب العالمين
تم تصفيته
وبموازاه المداهمه الامنيه بدات وحده
مكافحه الجرائم الالكترونيه برصد واستدعاء
وتوقيف كل من قام بالتحريض ضد رجال الامن
او التشكيك في جهودهم واكدت مديريه الامن
العام انها ستلاحق كل من يتناقل روايات
تسيء لرجال الامن او يتداول اشاعات مغلوطه
في البلاد
معنى من عمان وزير الاعلام الاسبق والناطق
باسم الحكومه الاردنيه الاسبق محمد
المومني اهلا بك مع الوزير يعني اليوم
حينما نتحدث عن هذه التطورات لنبدا من ما
ذكرناهم من الخبر الاخير وحده مكافحه
الجرائم الالكترونيه رصدتها ومن ثم
استدعته وبالتالي الى اين من الممكن ان
تصل ما اهميه ان همم تتحرك او يتحرك هذا
الجهاز في مكافحه كل الاثار التي حدثت ما
همم ما قبل وما بعد حتى مقتل الامير
شكرا لك الحقيقه هذا امر مهم جدا لانه في
عندنا مع كل اسف كم كبير من الضخ على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لاخبار مفبركه
واخبار كاذبه
وخطاب كراهيه تحرض
وتخلق بيئه قد تعبت بعقول البعضلي تدفعهم
لارتكاب الجرائم وبالتالي نعم تعاملنا مع
خليه ارهابيه استهدفت اربعه من خيار
شبابنا ومن فرسان الامن العام ورجال الامن
العام الذين يحافظون على الامن والاستقرار
ولكن ايضا لابد من الانتباه ان هنالك من
ضخوا اعلاميا وبسوشيال ميديا خطاب كراهيه
لعب بعقول البعض واجاجه وشكك وبث اخبار
مفبركه وكما تعلم هذا من شان ان يخلق به
حاضنا للتطرف والعنف وبالتالي لابد من
اتخاذ اجراءات بشانها ان اعتقد انه الراي
العام الاردني يقف بقوه خلف هذا الاجراء
كفانا كل هذا العبث تحت لواء الحريه
والحريه منه براء لابد ان يكون هنالك وقفا
لكل هذا الضخ السلبي في السوشيال ميديا
طيب وانت دعايات هاي لان من الممكن ان تصل
تداعيات ذلك سواء على مواقع التواصل او
حتى على مستوى انه الواقع الامني التغيير
في التكتيك الامني بعد مقتل ثلاثه في
عمليه معان وقبلهم همم الدلابيح
انا اعتقد التداعيات واضحه احنا الان
نستخدم اجهزتنا الامنيه على درجه كبيره من
الاحتراف تستخدم الادوات اللي متعرف عليها
من قبل الاجهزه الامنيه ولكن هذا الاجراء
همم المعمول به اليوم اتخذ سابقا ولكن
ربما ليس بهذا الوضوح وهذه الاقداميه لو
كان واضح انه هنالك محاولات حثيثه من اجل
استخدام السوشيال ميديا كسلاح لتقليب
البعض وخلق اجواء من الكراهيه التي ينبع
منها العنف ان اظن انه هذا مطلوب وهذه
حاجه وطنيه وهذا حفاظ على المجتمع عندما
يصل الامور بالتلاعب بعقل البعض ان
يستهدفون رجالا للامن لا تستطيع الاجهزه
الامنيه ان تقف مكثفه الايدي تجاه ذلك
تداعيات واضحه ان هذا اصبح امرا مهما من
اجل
ترسيخ الامن بمعناه العميق والحقيقي طيب
اليوم الدستور الاردني يكفل حريه التعبير
هذه الاحتجاجات او التظاهرات او حتى
يعني الرفض قد يقول البعض انها تم
استغلالها او تهيرها لاصحاب الفكر
التكفيري اين الخطا اين يكمن الخطا هو من
من خرج للاحتجاج ام هؤلاء استغلوا
وبالتالي صنعوا لهم بابا دخلوا منه الى
هذه الاحتجاجات
همم ايضا ملحوظه مهمه وهي جزء من النقاش
الوطني الدائر حاليا احنا لدينا ثلاثه
انواع من المحتجين هنالك المحتجين سلميين
بسبب الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الخانقه التي
تعيشها المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
الاحتجاج السلمي مقفول بالقانون والدستور
وبوصلات الدوله الاردنيه واضحه ان هذا
مسموح به ولا غبار على ذلك هنالك في اخرى
ثانيه تتحدث عن
احتجاجات سلميه ولكنها تستخدم ادوات عنيفه
تقطع الشوارع تعتدي على الشاحنات تقطع
الكهرباء عن بعض القرى هذا امر مجرم
بالقانون ويطبق عليه سيف القانون النوع
الثالث من المحتجين المحتجين الذين يخلقون
البيئه الحاضره للكراهيه والتطرف وهؤلاء
عاده ما يستخدمونه وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي واحيانا بعض وسائل الاعلاميه من
اجل الخلق حاله من البلبله التي يتولد
منها العنف هذه الانواع الثلاث رؤيه
الدوله واضحه واتت على لسان جلاله الملك
بذاته ان الاحتجاج
يكفله القانون ويكفله الدستور ولكن التعدي
على الامن والتعدي على همم استقرار
المجتمع وحياه الناس هذا ما لا نسمح به
اطلاقا طيب هل الانبياء تقوم بدور لكن
ايضا الحكومه اليوم همم اسمح لي مع الوزير
الحكومه ما الذي يمكن ان تفعل لتهدئه غضب
الناس من الواقع الاقتصادي الذي يعيشه
العالم وليس فقط الاردن اتحدث هنا عن
الاردن ما الذي من الممكن ان تقدمه
للمواطن لتهدئاته
انا بظن على مستوى الحكومه الان الحكومه
والنخب معنيين الحقيقه بشكل مباشر ان
ينخرطوا بشكل مكثف للحديث عن الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه ومسبباتها يعني يمكن
للحكومه تتخذ قرارات اقتصاديه ولكنها تقول
وتصر على ان القرارات الاقتصاديه التي قد
نتخذها الان سوف نتحمل تكلفتها بعد اشهر
قليله وبالتالي يجب علينا ان نتخذ القرار
الذي يحقق مصلحه الدوله العليا ولا يتماشى
مع اييه شعبويات قد تكون مضره على المدى
القصير حتى وليس البعيد همم احنا نتحدث عن
اوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه بسبب ماليه الدوله
وبسبب الارتفاع العالمي لاسعار النفط هذا
ما يجب ان نستمر بشرحه للمواطنين ويجب ان
نستمر بشرح الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الصعبه همم
للدوله هذا اعتقد ما يمكن فعله الان
الحقيقه على مستوى عقلاني من صعب جدا ان
نتوقع من الحكومه ان تقوم باي قراءات
شعبويه في هذه المرحله لانه نعلم ان
تكلفتها سوف تكون قاسيه على البلد بالمدى
المنظور ونعلم كما يعني لا نريد ان يحدث
بالاردن لا سمح الله كما حدث بدول شقيقه
قريبه منه عندما وصل الاقتصاد لحافه
الهاويه نريد ان نستمر
السير بطرق عقلانيه همم تحقق التوازن
الاقتصادي المنشود ونعمل ان شاء الله ان
نخرج من هذه الظائقه الاقتصاديه الكبيره
ونحقق معدلات نمو مرتفعه وتخفيض البطاله
لدينا بطاله مرتفعه وفقر مرتفع الكل يعلم
ذلك اوضعنا الاقتصاديه في غايه الصعوبه
همم بدات تؤثر على الاستقرار كما كما نشهد
في هذه الايام اوضاع على الاقتصاديه كنا
نعلم انها ستؤثر على الاستقرار لانه وضعنا
بالحقيقه صعب جدا لكن مستمرين ان شاء الله
بكل ما نستطيع ان نتعامل مع هذا الامر
باقصى درجات الحكمه شكرا جزيلا نالي وزير
الاعلام الاسبق مناطق باسم الحكومه
هل اسبق محمد المومني شكرا جزيلا لمعالك
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات انه واضرابات تل والاخرى تهزا
الشوارع مختلف المدن الايرانيه في تحدي
صريح لسلطات الايرانيه التي تصرف على
مواصله تم المحتجين حيث بدا اصحاب المحالب
تجاريه في مختلف المدن الايرانيه اضرابا
على العمل وذلك استجابه للدعوات التي تم
توجيهها في وقت سابق كانت عده جهات بينها
جمعيات ومجالس عماليه وكذلك ايضا طلاب
جامعات وطلاب مدارس من مختلف عن حيران قد
دعوا لهذه لهذا الاضراب الذي يستمر لمده
ثلاثه ايام شمل الاضراب اغلاق التجاريه
وعدم شراء من المتاجر وعدم الذهاب الى
العمل والتطهر في الشوارع تهدف الاضطرابات
الاخيره يعني احتجاج ايضا على جرائم
السلطه الايرانيه مثل الاعدام هم على
الاتقال الاغتصاب على حد وصف
[موسيقى]
على وقع انتهاكات النظام الايراني ضد
المحتاجين في ايران وحملات الاعتقال
والاعدام والاخفاء طلبه بلجيكا رعايها
بمغادره ايران محضره من مواجهتهم خطر
الاعتقال التعسفي وذلك بعد ان ورد ان احد
عمال الاغاثه وهو بلجيكي حكم عليه بالسجن
لمده تصل الى 28 عام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وصل المعارك الظاهريه المتواصله في مختلف
جبهات اوكرانيا تبرز معركه مخمود تجبها
رئيسيه بالنسبه للجانبين فبقدري ما يرغب
الاوكرانيون في ابقائها تحت سيطرهم بقدر
ما يطمح الروس الى دخولها صحيفه جورنال
الامريكيه وصفت ان المعركه معركه باخ موت
في شركه اوكرانيا ماتت اختبارات حاسما
لافاق موسكو العسكري تعد المعركات في
بخمرها خاصه لقائد العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا الجنرال سيرجي سولف
جيم الذي وعدته بتحقيق تقدم من ملموس هذا
في الوقت الذي قال قائد القوات البريه
الاخرانيه
ليست لها اهميه استراتيجيه بقدر ما لها من
اهميه النفسيه
للاوكرانيين والروس
معا
عموما دعونا نتعرف على اهميه هذه المدينه
ولماذا تعد اختبارا حاسبا لكل طرف جغرافيا
باخ متقع على ضفتين نهر
شماليه مقاطعه دونيسك في اقليم دومباس
شرقي اوكرانيا تبلغ مساحه المدينه 41 كم
وصل عدد سكانها الى سبعين الف سنه قبل
الحرب بسبب الحرب فره 90% منهم وقال لحاكم
الموالي لاوكرانيا تكمن اهميه هذه المنطقه
بالنسبه للجانب الروسي كونها البوابه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه شبه الوحيده لتقدم
قواتها في عمق منطقه تونس اما بالنسبه
للدفاع عن باقي مدن تونس كما انها تستغلها
لتوجيه ضربات النحو المواقع الروسيه في
الاجزاء الخاضعه لسيطرتهم بما فيها مدينه
[موسيقى]
مناكير بمعنى مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
حذيفه على ما انك عدت او تعبت عن اباخ موت
قليلا قبيله اقل من ساعتين لكن ما ابرز
مشاهداتك هناك
حمد لله على السلامه قبلها نعم تحياتي
عادل
نعم تحياتي عادل في الحقيقه جبهه باخمود
يعني الحديث عنها يطول جدا جبهه باقبو هي
جبهه عريضه طبعا هنالك يعني حديث عن مدينه
باخبط وتسمى الجبهه جبهه باخو لكن جبهه
باخو هي تشمل عدد كبير جدا من القرى
والبلدات والمدن الصغيره لماذا تسمى بجبهه
باخ مثل عند الغرض الاساسي للجيش الروسي
من هذه الجبهه العريضه هو الوصول الى
عمليه حصار ترامب لمدينه باقوت من جميع
الجهات وهذه استراتيجيه معروفه اتبعها
الجيش الاوكراني وكذلك اتباعها الجيش
الروسي تبع الجيش الاوكراني في استعاده
السيطره على الاخر اتبعها ايضا في استعاده
السيطره على اخر صور وكذلك الجيش الروسي
في سيرفر
ذات الاستراتيجيه وهو التحرك في جمع عريضه
وواسعه هي تبدا من منطقه وتستمر في منطقه
نيويورك ثم بعد ذلك همم الى همم اكثرها ثم
بعد الى ضخمه المدينه وتتجه صعودا الى
سوليدارك كل هذه المنطقه تسمى جبهات باخبط
والحركه متزامنه من الجيش الروسي في جميع
هذه الجبهات على سبيل المثال اليوم شنت
القوات الروسيه هجوما متزامنا في 25
مستوطنه وبلده ومدينه صغيره في وقت واحد
في جبهه باخبط للوصول الى عمليه حصار
لاقتطاع هذه المدينه واجبار القوات
الاوكرانيه فيها على الانسحاب في الوقت
المناسب او حصارهم وبعد ذلك اجبارهم على
الاستسلام طبعا اهميه انها ستكون بعد ذلك
معقل للقوات الروسيه في اتجاه اهم مدينتين
تبقى يعني في دونيس وهي كرامه
طبعا مشاهداتي كثيره جدا هنالك طبعا خطوط
اساسيه هنا في خط النار صفر دخلنا الى خط
النار صفر ووصلنا الى اخر خندق للقوات
الاوكرانيه في مواجهه القوات الروسيه على
بعد 400 الى 500 متر فقط من مناطق تمركز
القوات الروسيه المشاه والخنادق والجنود
عدد كبير جدا من الخنادق عدد كبير جدا من
الجنود منتصرين في هذه الجبهه طبعا لديهم
همم الاسلحه الخفيفه وايضا المدافع
الخفيفه وما الى ذلك بعد ذلك الدعم طبعا
من المدفعيه ومن الدبابات
والدعم اخر طبعا من المدفعيه الثقيله ومن
خلفهم خطوط الامداد وخطوط الاندلس وكان
بالذخيره والسلاح وايضا
بالمؤن من الطعام وما الى ذلك يعني همم
هنالك وجدنا جنود يعيدون بانه سوف يصمدون
في هذه الحرب وانهم لن يتخلوا عن شبر من
هذه الاراضي يعني شكرا لحذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات
[موسيقى]
بعد اشد ان وجذب وخلافات كثيره اقر الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي سقفا لاسعار الغازي
اخيرا المتحدث باسم الجيك اعلن توافق
وزراء الطاقه في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي على
وضع حدنا اقصى لسعر الغاز عند 180 يورو
للميجا وات في ساعه اه ياتي هذا الاتفاق
بعد محادثات على شان الاجراء القارئ الذي
احدث انقسام في الراي بين دول الاتحاد في
الوقت الذي تسعى فيه الى مواجهه ازمه
الطاقه
حسنا رئيس الوزراء البريطاني رئيس سوناك
الجدله حول تلميحات بوقف الدعم العسكري
البريطاني لاوكانيا اكد سوناك اليوم خلال
اللقاء في رجاء يجمع قاد الدول شمال
اوروبا والبلطيق اضافه الى هولندا اكد ان
بلاده ستزود كيف بحزمه جديده من ذخائر
المدفعيه بموجب عقد تزيد قيمته عن 300
مليون دولار الوضع هناك ايضا قاده دول
تحالف الى قوه الاستطلاع المشترك الى
العقاء على مستويات الدعم العسكري
لافرانيه او زيادهتها العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
في مفاجاه غير السعر للرئيس الامريكي
قررت لجنه التحقيق في الهجوم على مبنى
كابيتال توجيه اربع تهم جنائيه بحق ترامب
كما خلصت اللجنه الى ان ترامب غير مؤهل
لتولي اي منصب الرسمي وقالت نائبه رئيس
اللجنه ان رد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ترامب التدخل فورا لمنع الواقعه يجعله
عديم الاهليه لتولي ايام منصب رسمي
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
حاملين كاس العالم ميسي ورفاقه يعودونا
الى الديار
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله اطلقت قوات الامن السودانيه
الغازي المسيء للدموع على تظاهره في شارع
القصر في الخرطوم هذا هو كان التنسيقيه
لجان المقاومه اعلنت عن تظاهرات اليوم تحت
عنوان اراده الشعب وحددت القصر الجمهوري
نهائيا
في باكستان كشف المسؤولونها بان عدد من
معتقل حركه طالبان في البلاد تمكنوا من
التغلب على حراس الشرطه في مركز النقلي
مكافحه الارهاب الامراض التي نتج عنه خطف
اسلحه الشرطه
والسيطره على المركز الواقع في اقليم خيبر
شمال غير غربي البلاد راح تجاوز عدد من
العناصر الشرطه واخرين داخل المركز
[موسيقى]
حضرت المفوضيه الاوروبيه شركه ميتا مال
ميثا الملكه لتطبيقات فيسبوك بسبب
انتهاكها لقوانين الاتحاد الاوروبي
لمكافحه الاحتكار من خلال تشويه المنافسات
في اسواق الاعلانات المبوبه عبر الانترنت
السوقيه وقالت المفوضيه انها سوف تحقق في
الامر وانه يمكن ان تفرض غرامه تصل الى
10% من حجم المبيعات العالميه الثانويه
للشركه
[موسيقى]
رفضت المحكمه العليا السويديه قررت ترحيل
الصحفي التركيه بولنت كنيس الذي تطالب به
تركيا من اجل اعطاء الضوء الاخضر الانضمام
السويدي الى حلف الناتو واوضحت المحكمه
الى ان هناك العديد من العوائق التي تحول
دون ارسال الصحفي وهو رئيس التحرير السابق
لصحيفه زمان التركيه الذي تتهمه انقره
بالتورق في محاوله الانقلاب عام 2016
كثيرا باب رزق عناوين
بعد نتائج
استقالته من رئاسه مجلس اداره تويتر
رئيس مجلس الرئاسه اليمنيه يكشف للعربي عن
وجود عناصر من ميليشيا الحوتي في المانيا
وينتقد ريهاناهم على موقف برلين من الازمه
الاردن مداهمه تطيح بخليه ارهابيه في معان
وتصفي قاتل الدلابيب والامن العام يبدا
بملاحقه المحرك
معركه باخ موته اعتبار حاسم لموسكو
ومفتاحها لدونيسكو اوكرانيه تدافع بقوه عن
حسنها الشرقيه
شكرا لكم
على راس السنه
[موسيقى]